by now you know how important it is to
tread goals and look at metrics but
other than tracking those goals how do
you affect them your routine as a
marketeer at a start-up should be based
on trial and error experimentation and
iteration is the most important thing
for start-up let's hear what some of our
experts have to say about this we did
some sort of behavioural studies of what
a new user to YouTube how they utilize
his service and the typically what we
would see would be the first time they
would come to the site would be through
some kind of viral marketing that maybe
they saw one of their friends share a
video maybe it's on MySpace maybe was an
email check out this video this is
really funny but the first time
generally it doesn't stick with them
they don't remember the site maybe
they'll remember the video but they
won't remember the site that it came
from because I think we get that all the
time where people would be sharing their
instant messages through emails just
check this thing out on the Internet
it's very funny
and you see it you laugh and you close
the browser window but I think the the
second time there would be another time
where somebody would share this another
video maybe be somebody else sharing and
then after a few times visiting the site
it starts kind of the logo starts kind
of thinking in a bit the the sort of
domain name starts sinking in a little
bit and what we would see is that people
would they themselves would type in
youtube.com into the browser and they
would actually go to the site themselves
and then from there it's about sort of
uploading their own videos finding their
own videos and sharing it so it kind of
spreads out that way but um we've always
kind of looked at you know it required a
lot of sort of effort with the design of
the site to be able to say within the
first five seconds that's the amount of
time window that you have to be able to
really grab the users because if and so
there's there was a lot of work that was
done on the Related videos on the right
side because the video that you were
sent may not be interesting at all or
may not be a beer sleep in terms of what
be interested in but something on the
right side would grab you same thing in
the front page there would be 10 videos
so we're always sort of any on any page
on YouTube that was always one link away
from starting another video and so in
case you got bored instead of closing
your browser I think psychologically
it's always easier to kind of spend more
time on a site rather than closing the
browser and going to do work and so
there's always something that's within
one click that can start another video
and if you don't like that again there's
another one click away from another
video one significant part of YouTube is
not the first video viewed but the
subsequent videos that hold experience
and so whether and we have different
metrics giving us different times but it
has been as high as something as what
has been as low as sort of the average
length session of YouTube is like 12
minutes but it's been as high by some
metrics as 28 minutes and that's
incredible when you consider the average
length of the videos whatever 30 seconds
to two minutes and so well one important
part of that is and not the first video
we're assuming that people are already
getting to the site but how do you get
them to watch that and click on the
second video and then after that how do
you get them to click on another video
and more importantly like if they get
disappointed by that second third video
how do you still get them to click on
the fourth fifth sixth seventh video and
the solution to that partly is the
Related videos on the right side and we
always put that high because that was
going to be your channel to get into
more content but then the follow-up
question and this is where we had the
smartest engineers at YouTube working on
this day and day out which was how do
you populate that relate to video one
server idea of thinking about the the
content on YouTube is you can think
about it and sort of almost different
islands that are connected somehow but
different Islanders their islands about
sort of singers and the different types
of genres of artists out there then
there's Islands as sort of movies
there's Islands that's related to
fashion and food and there's Islands
that's more directed towards kids so
there's all these different islands some
of them are bigger or some of our
content
that some of them are tiny but people
are very passionate about that and
they're all interconnected with graphs
and if you can visualize that then it's
kind of what if you are watching a
single video on one of these maybe it's
a big continent maybe it's a small
island
what do you populate with with all the
other videos on the right side and the
obvious approach is if you're watching a
content about cooking every video on the
right side is more about cooking and so
it's all in within the same island but
what if by the fifth video they're just
sick of watching cooking videos how do
you get them to watch something else and
so we realized early on but there's a
lot of testing involved with this is
what if we actually start stuffing in
different types of content in there so
what would be coming back from search
results would be the things that are
most related with this video is obvious
it's gonna be cooking but let's just say
artificially we take out 50% 75% of this
content we just make it so it's
impossible to show more than 25% related
videos is cooking then you start
actually feeding in this other content
maybe we find out that people that are
interested in cooking also like soccer
and so we start actually putting in 10%
of videos that's related to soccer and
we start and starting playing around
with this and so maybe people they're
interested in this abstraction of soccer
and sports if they're watching sports
videos maybe they're also interested in
watching football or maybe they're
interested in watching tennis and so we
started playing around with that this
idea of what percentage is tightly
related to the video that you're
watching how much of it is it's not
unrelated ever but there was a there was
a gorilla that went behind how do you
actually create this sort of loose
relationship they're still related
because we do know that people that
watch this content also watch this
content but it would be hard to explain
if you didn't look at what the actual
watching sessions and that patterns are
to be able to create that connection
between say food and football well that
that's probably an easy one to create
but so we started doing a lot of
research along these lines and trying to
create algorithms to be able to better
guess as to people that are watching
this video would also guess it would
also be interested in watching this
video but it took a lot of
you know sort of theoretical theories
and then testing those theories and
pushing this stuff out live and seeing
what the users would actually do and
then tweaking and tweaking and tweaking
that